for my talk of the table we're joined by
two people who are already getting a lot
of oscar buzz for the new movie
filmmaker and tv creator that's lee
daniels
you know him he's responsible for hit
projects like precious
lee daniels of butler and empire his new
film the united states
versus billie holiday stars
grammy-nominated singer andrea day
you know her too as the iconic jazz
singer rise up
it explores the often untold story of
her role in the civil rights movement
and how she became the target of a
government investigation
what is the government's problem with
billie holiday
why is the government always after you
my song strange fruit
it reminds them that they're killing us
reminds them
it reminds you too reginald
wow the united states versus billie
holiday has been nominated for two
golden globe awards best actress that's
for andrew and best original song
also for andrew day and lee daniels
joins us now both
good morning to you both it's so great
to see you
andra day let me start with you hi hi hi
hi lee
let me start with you andrew i was so
blown away by your performance
number one congratulations on your
golden globe nominations i suspect oscar
is coming soon
but we don't want to jinx it we don't
want to jinx it i get that
but this is your first ever acting role
how do you even begin to prepare
and then to prepare to play billie
holiday what was your process
well uh i mean first of all overcoming
fear
faith had a lot to do with it with me
because i i didn't want to do it at
first because i was just so terrified of
of um you know uh sort of dishonoring
billy holliday's legacy and then
dishonoring the great diana ross's
legacy and audrey mcdonald on broadway
but um it was trustingly you know i
think the very very first step was to um
to or one of the first steps was to
trust lee and and
um and i saw the script by susan lloyd
parks i spoke with lee
and and and understanding the story
which i was really happy to see as a fan
of billie holiday that the
story would be really vindicating her
legacy in the world um
because of his storytelling would get to
know this icon as not a tragic
drug addict but actually as the
godmother of the civil rights movement
which she truly was so
yeah she really was i mean lee you were
certainly known for thinking outside the
box certainly known for changing things
up
was andrew day you did you look at her
and think yeah that's my billy
no not at all no i didn't i had
and nor did she by the way yeah i had a
couple of actresses in mind
i had a couple of actresses in mind but
uh i
everybody was forcing me to to sort of
see her
and uh i finally saw her and
uh i found myself talking her into
uh auditioning and uh because she really
really honored billy and she wanted
we wanted to do this right we wanted to
tell the story right and she
really wanted to tell the story right
and once she auditioned it was uh
it was a no-brainer it was god working
gail i'd never seen anything like it
before
in my in my career andrea you it's
anthony you ended up
losing almost 40 pounds for this role
which i mean that's
that's a lot to go through physically
and you also said
you started actually drinking for this
part why did you do that
uh yeah because i
hate her all the time i put cigarettes
in her mouth drinking and smoking yeah
i started smoking cigarettes as well too
i i think it was just
you know i prayed a lot about this and i
had a peace moving forward and once i
had that peace i
i thought okay you know then i'm in you
know what i mean i'm
and i i you know had a piece about that
and it was because
the reality is you know for for instance
with billie holiday
i didn't want there to be a moment where
people are like and she doesn't really
know because you're hard-pressed to find
a candid photo of this woman without a
cigarette
in her mouth she drank a lot and so i
needed to know not just
what that looked like but i needed to to
really really understand what it felt
like in my body to be in the middle of a
conversation with someone and just
need a drink or to need to pick up a
cigarette and you know it goes back to
addiction which i think we all are
just manifest differently but i needed
to feel that i needed to live in that
space and i needed to feel
her through that because i think it is a
part of her story you know although it's
not her story it's
part of her story so lee andrew starts
drinking but you said for you you
decided to take a different course on
this movie what was that
yeah it's not really about it's not a
biopic a typical biopic
on billie holiday uh we've done that and
seen that with all right
i'm talking about you but for you
personally i'm talking about for you
personally
you were saying andrew started drinking
and you decided that you were not going
to drink
yeah i know i decided i wasn't going to
drink
listen i understand what um hitchcock
meant at the end of the day when he says
that martini shot
because by the time you finish shooting
at the end of the day you like
you know give me that give me and um but
uh
i um i have been struggling with this
for a while and uh
it was nice to finally i think to to
give
to do justice by billy i wanted to be
present and clear and sober for her
and it really was the hardest thing
it was the hardest thing i'd ever done
to just to sort of to give it up and
there's a stigma
with uh that's attached to addiction and
uh
it's a it's uh it's uncomfortable even
talking about it now but
i'm really proud of what it what it
represents to millions
of americans to uh to stop to stop
and i just wanted to chime in on what he
said i i have to give such
so much credit to lee because him being
so candid about his own struggles on set
i mean it fueled us as actors and it's a
part of why
i was saying okay i i want to get this
right not just for billy but for lee and
for everybody who's
struggled with this as i've seen in my
family so it really
changed and motivated our performances
the actors on set
yeah and this and i think that that's
what get godly
well i think that that's what it is that
gets the performances from people you
know people ask me how do you get these
performances
from people and i think it's just
transparency and honesty and oftentimes
it seems
it seems uh almost as if you're a little
nuts for being
frank and candid about where you are in
this space but i think once actors feel
comfortable
with that they sort of they give you
their all and
i'm really happy that andrew did all i
can and everybody i'm so glad that you
two
trusted each other because i had never
even heard of this story about billy
halliday's life
and the performance the story that
you're telling i can't wait for people
to see it
andrew day and lee daniels we thank you
we thank you both the united states
versus billie holiday premieres next
friday
on hulu